hey youtubers it's Charlie and this
season era has been so amazing that I
wanted to celebrate the last couple of
weeks before the finale by doing a
special series of bonus videos just
counting down to that last episode so
this video is gonna be my top 10 team
arrow moments you know the moments when
it's just the team itself these are
really just from season 2 and obviously
we don't know what's gonna happen in the
finale but I'm gonna do a bunch more
special stuff whenever that happens so
if you're finding me for the first time
these bonus videos will just post each
Wednesday before each episode airs be
sure to subscribe to get everything and
leave me suggestions in the comments for
future bonus videos there's basically
gonna be you know four weeks of bonus
videos because there's three more
episodes after tonight so here we go
careful for spoilers for everything up
to episode 19 if you're not cut up yet
but number 10 team arrow compares battle
wounds so this is just one of the many
clock king moments which i think is just
one of the all-around best team arrow
episodes this season it's awesome to
watch them train but then it breaks into
them trying to one-up each other with
all their scarves while they're
shirtless you've got grenade ludes
shotguns it goes on and on I think
Oliver really ended up winning that
contest but then the camera just pans
over to Felicity and she pulls her
tongue out it's this really fun moment
of horror comedy it's like saying all
those scars they have are something that
brings them closer together you know
even felicity biting through her tongue
although she doesn't really see it that
way if you were to accidentally stumble
into the arrow cave in that moment when
they're all shirtless comparing scars
he'd be pretty horrified but for them
it's actually this really fun moment
that they can bond and show off on each
other and it does a really good job of
teeing up some of the other felicity
moments that happen later on this list
number nine team arrow makes fun of all
of her psycho ex-girlfriends the show is
called arrow but we don't spend a whole
lot of time in Oliver's head making this
a rare moment where everyone including
the audience got to laugh at his expense
they're just shining a light on Oliver's
troubled history with women without
being too mean about it
I mean how often do you see a girlfriend
laugh about their boyfriends ex Sarah is
a real trooper I don't think a real
person would be so quick to smile about
that situation even from a writing
standpoint you know everyone always asks
the producers when is olicity going to
become a real thing and before the
season started they said that Oliver
would continue to have chemistry with a
number of women this season the new ones
so far have been
and Isabelle I always thought it was
funny that Moira said Oliver is a
terrible judge of character and in the
context she said it I think she was
implying that women are a huge weakness
for him and another big theme this
season has been you know sins of the
father and Oliver like father like son
has trouble with women number eight
Roy in sins Young Justice moment one of
the rare Beatty moments to make the list
but one of the bests Roy and send true
detective season two for the win they
take it on themselves to fight some
crime in the glades and sin has some
amazing cosplay and even though it ended
up getting a little bit scary for both
of them they had so much chemistry
together
I really want to see more stuff like
this in the future we really don't know
what's gonna happen to either their
characters Roy Orson but I'm crossing my
fingers that they both survive to season
three so we can get some more Young
Justice moments like this number seven
Slade breaks into the arrow cave one of
the best action scenes this season era
has some of the best fight choreography
you know thanks to stunt coordinator
James Bamford and everyone is great at
executing it but Stephen Amell and Manu
just looked like they didn't hold
anything back it's like this ballet of
parkour and broken glass with the
exception of Slade's really appropriate
you know welcome home line I think he
almost could have been a really cool
silent film it's actually scenes like
this that made me wonder why people
don't make more jokes about the you know
subtle implied ship between Slade and
Oliver and argue that his history with
Slade is every bit as personal as this
history with Felicity you know a la
olicity shipping Slade even called them
brothers you know and they're at war in
the biblical sense right now like Cain
and Abel which actually kind of makes me
think of the Winchesters number six
Oliver's you're my partner speech this
is pretty self-explanatory
Oliver literally tells Felicity how much
he needs her and why she's so important
to him it came after she'd been visiting
Barry in Central City for a couple weeks
and you can tell without her around he's
starting to fall apart it's just a
really good example of how she is
probably the most important member of
the team because Oliver would totally
end up turning into a weepy pile of
flesh without someone to give him some
clarity like Felicity does and you know
maybe the occasional hug number five
Roy joins team arrow where I kind of
fell into team arrow because of the
mirakuru drama but I think even if he
hadn't gotten injected Oliver would have
eventually brought him into the
he'd already been doing more and more as
his informant the mirakuru just kind of
accelerated that Roy Harper Arsenal
storyline to warp speed it's such a
special thing when a new person joins
the family that I really hope he sticks
around for a long time you know as in
survives to season 3 the producers have
said that the Dark Knight trilogy is one
of their guiding lights in the series so
I always wonder if they're gonna do the
arrow version of death and the family
you know the comic book story where the
Joker killed the Jason Todd Robin who
later ended up getting resurrected as
Red Hood interestingly enough because a
lot of you keep asking me whether or not
I think Red Hood is gonna be featured on
the show number 4 Felicity trains to
fight another amazing clock king moment
this was just one of the ways Felicity
took a stand after feeling like she got
left out of that battle wounds contest
it is at the same time the most adorable
and fun moment for her character this
season or at least one of the most fun
moments it was a pretty intense moment
in her relationship with Sarah I think
they found some common ground since then
but I always get the sense that Felicity
is watching her really closely like the
way Oliver's mother was watching Isabel
rochev I think that if Sarah ever did
anything to hurt Oliver then Felicity
would just explode on her in a hurricane
of fingernails and teeth I'll let the
tumblr fanfiction run with that story
number three Barry in the arrow cave
also one of the funniest team arrow
moments this season but it's really like
a moment that stretches across both of
Barry's episodes first they abduct him
into the cave and I told I'd like to
believe that Felicity is the one that
shot him but I think we kind of know
that it was Diggle then watching him
fanboy all over Oliver when he learns
his secret identity and then obviously
Oliver's reaction to it all I think
Oliver as opposed to Stephen Amell in
real life is not a patient man you know
Stephen Amell the actor takes a lot of
his personal time to interact with fans
on Facebook and it conventions but
Oliver on the other hand just barely
tolerates Barry quick question though do
you think that all of our secretly
enjoys that when people fanboy and
fangirl over him number two team arrow
confronts Slade in the Queen home the
hits the fan and everyone's blood
starts to boil I just love it when the
camera zooms in on the action and they
all converge on Slade you know you're
watching your TV and you just start
scooting and clothes really really quick
I actually kind of wonder what crossed
his mind in that moment he was
definitely crunching the numbers on what
it would take to kill them all but I bet
that evil Tinkerbell shado told him to
stop we really didn't learn about her
whispering him till episode 18 she's
really been informing all of his actions
this season so anytime he pauses I feel
like she's telling him something and my
number one team arrow moment this season
all of our kills count vertigo to save
felicity they didn't linger on the point
too much but if you remember
Oliver vowed not to kill anyone this
year that line plays in the intro to
each episode of this season I can't be
the killer I once was
so essentially he's breaking his first
commandment by killing the count and he
didn't even hesitate so if you had any
doubts about who the most important
person in Oliver's life was I feel like
this is the answer
just imagine what he would do if Slade
put Felicity in a similar situation he'd
probably kill every single one of those
mirakuru soldiers to save her I do think
the actual solution - Slade's problem
isn't going to involve killing him
though I think it's gonna be much more
complicated but this count vertigo
moment is the perfect example of how far
Oliver will go to protect the people
that cares about you know Felicity just
being at the top of that list so here's
a couple bonus moments that I had to
leave off the list just to keep it from
going to a hundred but I really wanted
to mention them Felicity on drugs also a
clock key moment Felicity and Oliver at
the rally from episode 13
Felicity telling Oliver to go save Thea
in episode 18 then that first time
Oliver came back to the arrow cave and
everyone had been watching Sara do
salmon ladders for hours Felicity taking
point during that clocking episode and
everyone rushing in to help her and then
I'm using Felicity as bait to catch the
dollmaker in episode 3 and something
that we haven't seen yet that I'm really
hoping the show does at some point is
Oliver actually physically training
Felicity you know like when she was with
that punching bag only for real like
he's been training Roy but now it's your
turn let me know what kind of team arrow
moments do you want to see that the show
hasn't done yet and remember tonight's
episode is actually a really big deal so
make sure you watch it be sure to
subscribe to get my video I'll be
posting it right out to the episode airs
and leave me suggestions for my future
bonus videos there's gonna be three more
and they'll just post you know each
Wednesday before the episodes there so
right now click here to get my episode
20 video for tonight I'll have the
annotation soon
post it and click here for my Q&A video
thank you so much for watching I'll see
you guys tonight
high fives
you